[Music]
this is unreal
conservative fire brand rush limbaugh
pushed the envelope
on talk radio and online commenting on
everything from pop culture
have we got fun in store for you today
to politics
for more than three decades let me tell
you who we
conservatives are we love people
the missouri native broke into radio in
the 70s
soaring to fame in the 80s with his own
nationally syndicated radio program
welcome to the rush limbaugh program at
one point the rush limbaugh show was the
highest rated talk radio show in the
nation
with millions of listeners known as
ditto heads
during that time limbaugh developed a
reputation for his polarizing views
and inflammatory rhetoric we have a
major
immigration problem in 2006 he famously
mocked actor michael j
fox for having parkinson's disease in
this commercial he is exaggerating
in 2012 he referred to a georgetown law
student as a [ __ ] and a feminazi
for backing insurance coverage for
contraceptives congratulations mr
president
limbaugh also promoted the false rumor
that president obama was
actually born in africa and used his
show to promote the false
birther conspiracy the popular radio
personality battled health issues
throughout the years
including hearing loss and opioid
addiction which led to a stint in rehab
in 2015 he downplayed the dangers of
smoking
five years later the cigar loving
limbaugh announced he had advanced lung
cancer
i have been diagnosed with advanced lung
cancer
a staunch supporter of president trump
the president awarded limbaugh the medal
of freedom in 2020
the nation's highest civilian honor he
is the greatest fighter and winner
that you will ever meet while some on
the left panned him as a divisive figure
limbaugh described himself differently
in a 1991 interview with 60 minutes
the most dangerous man no i'm a harmless
fuzzball his booming voice and combative
style helped pave the way for
other commentators championing
conservative causes
in the media michael george cbs news